romanticism is one of the most important
historical events of all time unlike a
lot of what gets called history
romanticism isn't a war or a piece of
technology or a political event it
refers to the birth of a new set of
ideas it's about a mind set in a way of
feeling romanticism began in Western
Europe in the mid 18th century in the
work of artists poets and philosophers
and it subsequently spread all over the
world changing how millions of people
look at nature children love sex money
and work we are all now more or less in
some aspects of our sensibilities
romantics romanticism is best understood
as a reaction to the birth of the modern
world and some of its key features
industrialization urbanization
secularization and consumerism what
follows are some of the central moments
in the history of Romanticism the Maya
Paris May 1762 the Swiss philosopher
jean-jacques rousseau publishes a book
about the raising of children amel or on
education it contains diatribes against
the oppressive world of adults and
praises the natural goodness spontaneity
and wisdom of little children it is a
point extremely anxious to get mothers
to breastfeed their offspring the first
sustained argument for this practiced in
Western civilization the world around
Rousseau is growing ever more rational
scientific and technologically based
it's increasingly sensible planned
sterile and bureaucratic against all of
this Rousseau emphasizes the child the
original rebel the representative of
everything that's pure and school and
outside of adult discipline is the seat
of creativity and genius for the first
time in Western history glamour is
directed not at the attainment of reason
and adult self control but at the
freedom from tradition and the natural
innocence and sweetness of the child
Brook Street London August 1770 a
precocious seventeen-year-old poet
called Thomas Chatterton down some
arsenic and ends his life in a
any attic apartment he kills himself
because no one wants to publish his
poetry which is concerned with beauty
and wisdom and because his
uncomprehending family are applying
pressure for him to become a lawyer a
cult soon grows up around the young
beautiful poet with shoulder-length
chestnut hair he becomes an emblem of
something that will become very
important for romantics the idea of the
sensitive doomed person often an artist
rejected by a cruel vulgar world
Chatterton stands at the head of a long
line of romantic heroes that will
stretch from byron to Keats to Van Gogh
and eventually all the way to Jim
Morrison an Amy Winehouse romanticism
borrows from Christianity the romantic
hero is a secularized christ-like figure
the loser who is in truth deeply Noble
in the eyes of the few who understand
Leipzig Germany 1774 the German author
Goethe publishes the quintessential
romantic love story the sorrows of young
Verta it tells the story of a passionate
doomed love affair between a young poet
called Vetter and a beautiful clever
young woman called Charlotte
unfortunately for Vetter Charlotte is
married so the love is impossible from
the very start
but that doesn't stop there - a dreamy
and practical young man who loves the
Arts above all else like Chatterton
Vetter is under pressure to have a
sensible career and joined bourgeois
life but he can think of only one thing
the impulses of his heart eventually
there - can't take it anymore and kills
himself but rather than condemning him
as a lunatic and a hothead Goethe one of
the founding fathers of Romanticism
directs all our sympathies towards
theater we're supposed to be on his side
admiring his passionate and entirely
impractical attitude to love the book
becomes the most popular novel of a
generation three million copies are
printed Napoleon declares it the
greatest work of European literature and
it dramatically changes how many people
think of love privilege engrain
of a more traditional rationale concerns
for class lineage and money for a
romantic it's always right and Noble to
follow your heart the disastrous results
that follow aren't any argument they're
just proof of how des
gated and heartless the so-called adult
sensible world can be Madrid Spain 1798
the artist Francisco Goya produces one
of his most iconic images titled the
sleep of Reason brings out monsters it
captures a quintessential romantic
interest in the limits of reason and the
power of the irrational over humans
fragile minds to be romantic is to have
sympathy for madness and to hold an
almost vengeful attitude towards
bombastic claims as to the crime of
rationality science and logic the Lake
District England December 1799 a young
English poet called William Wordsworth
and his sister Dorothy move into what
set to become one of the most famous
residences in the history of English
literature dove cottage in grasmere on
the edge of the Lake District here they
will spend the next nine years and
Wordsworth will write some of the
greatest poetry in the English language
celebrating something that's very under
threat the natural world he'll write
about daffodils oak trees clouds
butterflies and rivers and his work will
charm and seduce Europe within a
generation there will in Wordsworth own
estimation be more tourists than sheep
in the Lake District most importantly
running through Wordsworth's poetry is
an abiding hatred for everything
mechanical and industrial when many
years later a railway line threatens to
pass through the Lake District
Wordsworth and his followers do
everything they can to have the Train a
symbol of Wordsworth hated technology
re-routed to be a romantic is to take
the side of nature against industry its
to prefer a daffodil to a viaduct a tree
to a factory at the moment when huge
swaths of Britain are being covered in
the often monstrous new cities that are
making Europe rich Wordsworth the
quintessential romantic speaks up for
the natural and a simple life
Niagara United States September 1829 the
American painter Thomas Cole paints one
of his most characteristic images of the
mighty Niagara Falls with a couple of
Native Americans in the foreground Cole
makes his name as a painter of sublime
scenes vast landscapes of the American
interior showing nature at its most
dignified and impressive
man looks lost and puny by comparison
this too is a typical romantic attitude
for romantics don't believe in God but
they go in search of the emotions one
might once have had around religion and
locate them in a big wide-open spaces of
nature to be a romantic is to find
relief from the pressures of competitive
city life in a sort of natural grandeur
that transcends all human achievements
and concerns Westminster London April
1847
14 years after some fairly incompetent
officials destroy the British Parliament
with fire a new building reopens
designed by a rising star architect
Augustus pujan oddly even though the
building is new it's made to look old
very very old medieval in fact it's full
of suits of armor and seated angels when
the architect pujan defends the building
he argues that his building is Noble
because it harks back to his country's
pre-industrial past before it grew
obsessed he's careful to add with money
or technology it begins a cult of the
Middle Ages a big theme in Romanticism
which identifies in the world of knights
and castles a nobility that is thought
missing from the factories and shopping
arcades of the modern world
Sarge Armour Paris May 1863 the French
poet childhood Lehr writes a prose poem
celebrating an unusual character whom he
calls a flaner a stroller or loafer a
casual wanderer who has no particular
job to go to
and just spends his time observing busy
street life of a modern city threading
his way through the crowds strolling
instead of rushing sampling people's
conversations and creating narratives
for other's lives
Baudelaire a typical romantic admires
the flannels playfulness and lack of
practicality this person isn't a waste
of time it doesn't matter that he
doesn't have a job for Baudelaire he is
a prince
unlike the boring wage slaves rushing to
the new offices of capitalism lieu of
April 1891 the French painter Paul googa
set sail for Tahiti hoping to escape
everything that is artificial and
conventional he lives in the Pacific
South Seas on and off for the rest of
his life drawing young native women
looking relaxed and natural without
anything on they are in his eyes
evidence that civilisation is what
made us sick a core romantic belief the
romantic movement has permanently
changed our sensibilities as the world
has grown ever more technological and
rational Romanticism has come to stick
up for the irrational the untrained the
exotic the childlike and the naive there
is naturally something a bit adolescent
and immature within Romanticism but then
again there can be something rather
heartless cold dogmatic and arrogant in
many aspects of modernity one hopes this
isn't going to be the end of the story
that we may in the future learn to
soften the worst sides of modernity
through the best sides of Romanticism in
order to create a more evolved
alternative what one might term an age
of maturity
you